our top story new information in the
case of the man accused of killing
investigative journalist Jeff gearman
thanks for being here I'm Denise Valdez
and I'm Brian Loftus prosecutors say
they will not seek the death penalty
against Robert Tullis that's why the
former elected official claims he's
innocent 8 news now investigator vessel
Murphy reports on what unfolded in court
Robert Tellis pleading not guilty to
murder here in court this appearance
marking the first time his former
co-worker saw him since his arrest said
some prayers and also just looked at him
and was just um
very saddened by what had happened and
how somebody could do the things these
stars were doing assistant public
administrator read or read and her
co-workers in the courtroom as their
former boss Robert Richards is charged
with murder are you familiar with the
judge that you're facing yes right do
you understand that charge yes sir
not guilty
you saw both faces both sides of him and
not everybody saw the evil side that we
did prosecutors announcing they will not
seek the death penalty against Telus the
former Clark County public administrator
is accused of killing review journal
investigative reporter Jeff gearman on
September 3rd Telus lost to the
Democratic primary to keep his position
after Reed and other employees worked
with Garmin to expose problems under
telus's leadership Reed wears a pin with
a photo of the slain journalist after
court she and her team had back to the
office gearman worked to fix Jeff
gearman
foreign
you know gave his life
um whose life was taken to make a
government office better and we are
forever grateful for Jeff for that
the next court appearance for Telus is
set for November 2nd reporting at the
Regional Justice Center in downtown Las
Vegas Vanessa Murphy 8 News Now